dostoevsky wrote in the idiot my
favorite of his books
through the main character prince
mishkin that beauty will save the world
these words seemingly naive and
ultimately at least to me profound what
do they mean to you beauty will save the
world naive really
i don't think they seem naive at all
well uh sheldon jensen actually for his
1970 nobel prize
speech talked about this line a lot
and he thought for most of his life that
was a silly line there was just words
thrown out there because
with all the suffering that's in the
world what has beauties actually ever
done oh my god i hate this so much
i i trash about soldiers yeah i
am okay um
and this is perfectly sets up this theme
you know i said let's do this episode
start the new year on a positive note
give people hope give people joy uh you
and i both have friends who are models
right
and it's a silly profession to some
extent of course
but
you are actually a model you are my
friend yeah that's right that's true i'm
another model i was trying to be subtle
but for those people who actually you
know deserve to be models
um when you look at someone who is a
model
and in some of their photos
and these these people look perfect now
in real life they're not perfect they
have flaws they'll be the first to admit
it so on and so forth but when you look
at beauty
it is almost impossible
to maintain a sense of cynicism and
hopelessness
because if there's even one moment when
some
uh element of perfection has been
actualized if there's one moment where a
beauty has been realized and captured
you can't say well it's never gonna
happen again
so i think beauty
it means hope
i think
i hate
that cynical idea of like um
i get i i appreciate solzhenisson's
broader point in that a lot of times
people there's something called the
deepity where people throw words
together to sound profound and if you
take it apart like this is just complete
gibberish i don't think this is an
example of that i think
beauty inspires and it more importantly
it proves to you
this is something that can actually
happen on this earth plato right the
platonic theory of forms like this world
is imperfect but these perfect forms
exist another dimension and that's where
our concepts come from you know he was
an early
person trying to figure out where our
concepts come from and epistemology and
so on and so forth um
but that is something that is real in
here
so i completely disagree with uh his
analysis of that and i don't know if
it'll save the world but it's certainly
a prerequisite and what's the point of
fighting
for your values if you don't want to
make the world a more beautiful place
well it's also how you define beauty
because beauty could be just aesthetic
beauty it could be art of course art
could be could encompass
a lot a lot more than just literature
and paintings it can encompass
the full
life the full dance of life
but then beauty could be something
just uh
deeper like
whatever that aw you feel
when you pause
and hear the music
just
hear
and like look up at the stars like for
some reason when i see rockets go up for
me it's like science what is that
the awe that we're able to accomplish
that as humans you know that's funny
because you know there's lots of
different schools of thought like these
people versus these people and
you know maybe vegans versus
steakhouse people
i think in terms of the sciences and i
guess you and i would be on opposite
sides here
you have the
astronomy people versus the zoology
people like the the big question is
would you rather
spend
10 minutes on the moon or would you
rather spend 10 minutes in the deep sea
and for me it's clearly the deep sea
um the zoology that's down there uh
there's something i would encourage
people to look up uh called deep staria
which is a jellyfish then they the
scientists what's amazing when you watch
these deep-sea dives
on youtube is that the scientists are
they're they're nature dorks like
everybody else they went into this field
and there's none of this
maybe soulja nation-style cynicism of
when they see an amazing animal in its
natural environment you know exhibiting
these crazy behaviors they lose it
they're on the mic like oh my god like
it's so exciting to watch so
uh i i'm not a rocket person but i'm
definitely a zoology so animals and
plants in the sea and also it's so
mathematical there's so much so many
forms there's there's this um
there's this plant called aerospermum
titan up soybeas
i don't know how to pronounce it because
they're always in latin you never hear
them pronounced you said sperm area
sperm yeah because it's a woolly seed is
the is the genus
um the leaf it's just always puts out
one leaf
but the leaf is covered in little
magnifying glasses
uh lenses to make it maximize the
sunlight so it looks like this little
crystal seashell it's tiny it's like two
centimeters but it's just this amazing
thing that that grows out of the
sands in south africa
you